you welcome welcome island people
welcome to off the rails
wow guys
wow
wow wow wow this is off the rails my
dudes
turn back a flat flaming turd a bag of
flaming turd today's off the rails we
have such a fun episode
I am so excited for our main segment
today which is gonna be can you guess
which crew member is high
an unknown amount of crew members I'm
gonna step out of the office they're not
high yet so
right maybe again yeah maybe good maybe
dad
an unknown amount of crew I'm gonna step
out of the office
are you guys going to how are you guys
going to ingest the uh
you're gonna you're gonna
smoke a joint or something is that the
idea yes uh we will be smoking marijuana
cigarettes
Blaze
taking a fat bomb grip anybody
I suggested that we should do bong and
everybody vetoed me real fast because
that would just be absolute mind blast
yeah
I think I understand now why I don't
like smoking weed it's because when I
first started I didn't start with like a
little puff on us on a stick I hit a it
was bong grips all day every day yeah
blast off to outer space with Jeff Bezos
yeah it's going zero to 100 wow so I'm
gonna step out an unknown amount of crew
members are gonna get high and I'm going
to interrogate them one by one and try
to identify who is high
sick exciting
it's gonna be fun
well today's spawn uh today's sponsors
are cracking me undies and upstart thank
you thank you peace and love peace and
love peace and love also this episode if
it's coming out on Thursday the the new
Yuri
sekiah collection is out check this out
I love this hoodie so much
yeah oh
[Music]
we've been talking about it all week so
but yeah it comes out Thursday 10 a.m
PST
and
we're super excited so
set your alarm clock people
this is a craft I open Teddy fresh but I
went to this craft Mayo
meme with 16 likes
you know I
you know
craft mail really [ __ ] up collabing
with
what was it a bar stool idiots man it's
so stupid
anyway let's not let's not dig up old
trauma
so
first of all a few things we're gonna
just do at the top of the show here some
great stuff too and after the break
we're gonna get right into it you know
first of all I want to address there's
been there's someone we haven't talked
about in a minute
who'd that be old Ye Old
my former bestie
Trisha Paytas
oh she hasn't done anything recent so
this isn't like
but actually I mean like somebody this
girl uh contradictions of they on Tick
Tock who is like I guess
has a whole Tick Tock account dedicated
to
debunking Trisha uh claims and stuff
uh it's pretty incredible
she and and the account is a hundred
thousand followers so like
what the [ __ ] there's like a whole
Community dedicated to
debunk all right like I said
contradictions but the reason I'm
bringing it up today is because there
was a video posted yesterday that's gone
like kind of viral on tick tock
and it has 3.5 million views after a day
he said I made fun of him 600 000 likes
it's about my Tourette's
and I didn't even know she she did this
she went on this podcast with uh Jordan
Belfort The willful Wall Street guy
who's reinvented himself somehow it's
like dude you're a criminal bro like I
don't understand how people are cool
with this guy just being like I'm an
influencer now I made a billion dollars
ripping off Working Class People now I'm
an influencer
told you to talk to me nice Ethan I mean
he's it had this whole Redemption Arc
right where he like acknowledges that
everything that he did was horrible and
yeah but he's still living like a
million dollar house or like
multi-million dollar house where does
that money come from
dude still has money from it right he's
Rich it's obvious
so he obviously stashed by anyway
whatever it's not about him it's about
Trisha
and the video was really really well put
together
but the reason that I'm really annoyed I
just I don't know if you people who
follow me on Tick Tock I basically just
stopped
making tick tocks at this point because
every [ __ ] video I upload
um gets removed by them every time for
some stupid reason like three out of
four of my last videos got taken down
like here I'll show you I may I just
made a video of me reacting to it right
excuse me
I just made a video of me silently
reacting to that tick tock
here it is and it got removed for hate
speech
against myself
but the original's still up so like I
don't know if somebody over there some
James Charles stand hit like three of my
last four videos were removed
yeah they have it immediately too like
immediately not like oh they were up for
a minute your algorithm is actually
getting crushed there's a lot of people
that complain about that but I think
this is real evidence well how do you
explain that their original video is up
and then mine tastes down for hate
speech against my [ __ ] self I agree I
really do think that it's not like your
your account has been uh blacklisted by
somebody they let me post it and then
after like 10 minutes it's just right
but like I just can't make anything it's
really frustrating I can't even make
videos about myself
it's like what the [ __ ] anyway so let's
watch this video
I made by the way the top comment is me
thank you did I finally make it to
Tourette talk
thank you
that's true [ __ ] yeah you guys know you
guys get the joke right yeah yeah thank
you all right here's the video now I
didn't even realize she was talking
about me on this podcast because you
know after a breakup she did like the
Ethan is a piece of [ __ ] World Tour
and uh well shout out to this person for
I guess having my back if I don't know
if that was their intention but they did
a really good job of showing so here it
is he said I made fun of him for his
when they were clearly jokes why is that
a problem I don't know I have a problem
once the show ended he was like oh she's
anti-semitic and she made fun of my
Tourette we had Tourette's yeah he has
he has like Tourette's but I didn't make
fun of him like it's the same way he
called me what he happens he's just
saying that to just be cool by the way I
love that take yes I'm saying I'm saying
I have Tourette's to be cool and woke
yeah
as everybody well knows the Tourette's
cool now he's so cool that's something
that people
pretend to have to be cool actually
probably Trisha probably would do
something like that
I don't know if it's cool it's just I
don't know but yeah it's great to be
like woke or something I think he really
has stress okay well that's a real
problem yeah of course but once that
show ended it's like she's anti-semitic
she's running into my spreads so now I'm
like an ableist but it's not Tourette's
Tourette's is like when you I have
Tourette Syndrome no tourettes is when
you're like [ __ ] this just [ __ ] isn't
that Tourette's
I love having a farmer Tourette's
because now I can like have a soapbox
for something all your attack should be
about having tourettes and like you know
I don't want my whole existence to be
defined by the guy with direct that's
what you gotta do you got to like go for
a thing that people feel sorry for you
for you as like this guy because you're
just as messed up as me I mean you got
Tourette so you got something like your
brains so your brain is not wired all
the way right what yes it's like blind
beating the blind like you're not yeah
it's the blind leading the blind damn
yeah I have Tourette's therefore I'm in
Cape I'm basically incapable of uh yeah
well I'm just I'm basically a vegetable
yeah
good thing I have a care
one of the most triggering things I
would say that Trisha did consistently
throughout the show was telling me that
I don't have Tourette's or try to tell
me what Tourette's is
like dude stop and you know the problem
with that especially is like like people
already misunderstand Tourette's like
it's a harmful stereotype the people
that scream obscenities are like five
percent of people with Tourette's with
the most severe
um condition and I mean God bless them
it's so difficult to live with that
super high end
uh Tourette's but most people have a
condition like mine and it's a very
harmful stereotype that that it's just
you know
everyone has the worst possible
condition of it you don't think five
percent is
five percent
said five percent of people have that
kind of Tourette's oh
five percent is everything five percent
he takes that five percent
it's amazing how it comes down it all
comes back around to five percent were
you setting that one up or were you just
like no that's a real stat wow unreal
full circle baby full send full circle
that's right
you so much better than me your bride
has Tourette's
that's like your physical that's like
the brexit version of your hand knowing
that we're like cool and friends like
it's fun to have someone like Tourette's
just like Moses is like my middle
eastern I don't I never had a promo
tourezzo so I do think it's kind of cool
because it's like why we can make threat
jokes about the bread pretty epic by the
way Moses is my middle eastern
I was a Muslim you were a Muslim man
and I was her Tourette's exactly like
Pokemon for her to collect
[Laughter]
gotta catch them all
right and stuff I mean you're making all
the jokes oh oh our waiter close
Tourette's Tick Tock is a big thing
right now I forgot to tell you I'm not
I'm not
going to wash assistance and they can't
do it but that's not I don't have that
issue but just maybe something with your
hand just put it on tick tock
[Music]
I know I always bring this up but it
does sound like you have to try it or
something like that I mean this is just
some shitty-ass political website crap
yeah it's garbage
it is you can't control it
you don't know
because it's funny stop you're out of
line smoke that weed baby it's [ __ ]
420 yes traps yeah
[Music]
can you just enjoy the video why do you
need to diagnose his mental illness
like retardation not to be mean wait you
just called her [ __ ] you called
Dixie mental retardation which is like a
lot of people think that's crossing the
line I have you know mental illness I
have some form of retardation in me I
don't think it's to me it's not enough
she's some form of retardation ladies
and gentlemen
yeah a lot of this I haven't seen I
think
I have some form of retardation
Trisha Paytas
bored I was just like oh there's
something there's a there's something
off so I was like oh she danced to the N
word in 2020 when it was it's just about
like an off thing after I got out of the
ER I didn't know what to do I felt so
crippled but people love a crippled in
bed so it was fine kind of like [ __ ]
a dead person so now I'm like an ableist
he said I made fun yeah so
it's all old news you know it's just
interesting that it's going viral now
but most interesting to me is that I did
a hate crime on myself for basically
reposting the video so apologies to me
I'm sorry me from Tick Tock is
protecting myself well don't be stupid
right yeah fair enough good advice you
should probably apologize to Tick-Tock
user base as well I apologize to user to
Al The Tick Tock community and mostly to
myself for committing a hate crime on
myself I think it's maybe the Tourette
talk that's reporting you maybe they're
upset that you weren't their official
representative Maybe
you should listen to Trisha
you would have been safe interesting
trust me you're not that guy yeah if you
guys are curious what mine looked like I
mean it was just
well what bothered me too is people were
saying I deleted it and there was like
conspiracy theories going around I'm
like dude it's not me [ __ ] Tick Tock
keeps removing it
it's literally just me watching like
this
[ __ ] hate crime dude
okay
maybe it's a hate crime attrition
because
no I'm not going to say that
um also since we're talking about Trisha
I just thought [ __ ] it let's just go in
for a little [ __ ]
just have a moment here
sure new music video
dude the production is insane
this is the teased
what is it the the shape of water is
that what this this sea Critter is yes
yes so
she's saying the whole thing in Hebrew
oh we're gonna get claimed by superbam
whatever the [ __ ] whatever
I'm pretty sure she does meant the man
claim manually I don't think so we'll
definitely get claimed
I'll just anyway here maybe I'll just do
like this then finally just show you
still the visual is yeah is the
importance I'm trying to promote her
music video because I was gonna say like
I just couldn't be nice about it like
the production quality is insanely good
yeah I imagine this was a very expensive
shoot which makes me also wonder
whoa they I don't know how they're
making money and it makes me nervous and
they're spending a lot of money that's
making me nervous right so none of my
production costs well return on
investment on this is going to be close
to zero five percent not even five they
wish
but I'm trying to show Moses's
prosthetic here around the 37 second
mark
this is such a sad State of Affairs
where you have to [ __ ] comb through
stills
here I'll show a brief clip here
and she did it all in Hebrew
oh
wait what happened oh you muted it yeah
that's such a shame
it's definitely gonna get claimed
it's only has 50 000 views I mean
but anyway like
[Music]
yeah they did a full body prosthetic on
Moses that looks incredible so I want to
give a shout out you know they went all
out for it but I'm very concerned about
their finances I know it's none of my
business but um
what would you say this is like a 200
000 shoot I'd say
um it could be easily I mean water
shooting the makeup the rain the
lightning I mean the location I mean
getting unless they didn't get permitted
but I mean it seems like now yeah they
get permanent well yeah so I mean you
know shooting on
uh that's right on Santa Monica Beach
is it yeah you can see Santa Monica in
the background oh okay at one point with
all those rocks I thought it was further
uh
yeah yeah I mean there's night shots
that night lighting and everything what
do you think of that is yeah I guess you
might be right
but I mean shout out to the production
team but I don't [ __ ] see it oh there
we go I don't see how they're making a
dime on this [ __ ] oh my God
and that five percent ain't what it used
to be I'll tell you that
not many people watching Frenemies these
days oh I see what you're saying yeah
you're five percent it's not what it
used to be yeah no no no it doesn't pay
for this
five percent
so I don't know I'm gonna upload it see
Auto Branch
Olive Branch
and in fact I'm gonna promote it go
watch the video too
because they're gonna be bankrupt if you
don't
they're gonna lose everything if you
don't go watch this video
yeah in fact are there any clear shots
of of the makeup I really just want to
see it's hard it's hard I know I'm
trying to find here it's in the
beginning 216. here let's just watch
kind of a spicy little thing I like that
that the Island Boy The Island Vibes I
was about to say the Big Island Vibe
look at this this is crazy production
dude
super high level [ __ ]
yeah and there's a shot of him on the
beach it's full body prosthetic like he
has a whole back prosthetic
it's insane man yeah I mean the
Prosthetics itself too never mind like
the makeup artist actually paint it and
everything uh
be very very expensive here you see that
that's the [ __ ] I was talking yeah
anyway
there you have it and in Hebrew too for
I don't know why I don't know who that's
for like who's that for
state of Israel of course
is looking for Hebrew music
Jesus what was that
if that was Trisha screaming what was
the context of her screaming Jew I
believe it was during the uh
um episode where you guys were driving
in the car and there was a menorah on a
lawn yeah oh and she just screamed you
yeah nice classic moment that's what I'm
saying I'm like dude the only people
that screamed Jew when they see Jewish
paraphernalia are [ __ ] Nazis soldiers
like who does I'm just saying I'm not
I'm not calling her but I'm just saying
that's what I was trying to explain to
her is like your fascination with Jewish
people
is only shared with Nazis
uh peace and love peace and love thank
you Trisha good luck on your music video
Island Boys remix
the island boys my dudes we have Island
Boy updates
we have huge island updates
shout out to the island huge
Island updates my friends love love
first of all are you with us love I am
you are the island boy I mean you are
the first to come out of the closet as a
fan yeah and um well you somehow
arranged last night in the middle of the
night [ __ ] Swedish time you got on
the Instagram live with the island boys
what the [ __ ] bro
yeah well I got some connects in the rap
rap business so you know they connected
me with the island boys yeah they're but
seriously how did how did this happen
well okay so for real
um I paid them 30 bucks to make give me
a shout out on their Instagram
and um then later I thought they were
streaming and I I thought I have to try
to come in and they invited me oh that's
awesome yeah did you ever get the shout
out
yeah but it I don't know I I had to kind
of threaten them a little bit
because they they dipped on me for a
while when I sent the money how do you
threaten them over the Internet what do
you say well I tend to
I kind of pulled some strings you know
said I was with the entry broadcast and
you leveraged your uh your connections
huh well I had to I mean it was there
was 30 bucks on the line so yeah 30
bucks is everything yeah who's gonna how
else are you gonna pay the hosting fees
on uh Ethan's fee yeah exactly I need
that money by the way what's Ethan's
feet up to I haven't checked up on that
well not a lot nowadays
shame
traffic is slowing down well let's do
something about that
cookies now you're tracking my cookies
bro what kind of put the best way now
I'm doing it legally
so wait wait wait wait is this accurate
2100 yeah that
um yeah in two months as cam got his cut
yet I'm actually four feet that is cut
oh tried to send it to him but it's
going to good uses guys it's going to
good uses interesting
yeah
he's building a game or some [ __ ] I
don't know he's up to some kind of you
know what Shredder does have good
shredder has cute feet like he deserves
to be on here
shoe size 100 wow ah look at this it's
so cute it's a fixed it's a close-up of
[ __ ] it's fun
look at this it's so funny
it's a close-up on Shredder's feet
that's the best I love that oh that's
such a that's the best foot shot ever
oh my God skate spark what is that a
reference to something
skate park yeah
what are you looking at it says
birthplace skate park oh I didn't write
that who wrote that oh because he shreds
of course oh you're oh are you setting
up a joke for me what was that no I
these are these are all users yeah this
is user generated oh so a user put those
in
yeah let's see how Fredo feed picks duh
those are cute
that's the best I love this feet pics of
dogs is my favorite thing
birthplace fettuccine fettuccine come on
so
um anyway here's the uh conversation
enjoy
oh yeah
oh yeah wait what do you do exactly
uh video editing right okay yeah I knew
you'd be on the scenes type guy hey bro
um why bro was hating on me and my
brother like that
bro
yo
yeah why was why was it um why was he
hating on us the the guy with the beard
the guy the guy with the gray in the Box
let's talk about Dan the hater of course
well hold on he says the guy with the
gray right here did you hear that oh
[ __ ] but I I'm a fan I know I think he
is talking about being but he might have
just confused us a little bit yeah it's
confusing yeah because I I'm an island
boy uh you are definitely yeah he knows
you're an island boy okay good I just
wanna I don't want him to think that I'm
a hater right it's the furthest thing
from the truth love I can't help but
notice you're doing some of the same
movements that they do I saw you
grabbing your chin and doing all that
yeah I'm trying to like blend in yeah
by the way I I put on notifications on
on their Instagrams
and I got the notification at 7 00 am in
the morning
um
so just as as I went to bed I had to
grow up again and like put clothes on
yeah but this is emergency
yeah for sure yeah thank you for doing
that
it's so stupid play it and then it mutes
it doesn't freaking Reddit moment he's a
hater right yeah did you see the robot
in the back that was me
oh that was you yeah oh uh above his
shoulder I said he was fireman
I love the island I'm trying to wonder
who is he in the show because I know who
the guy with the ashy here he's been on
YouTube Forever
oh yeah well we're all like uh like we
all helped behind the scenes and we're
all like do the show together
Ethan is on the phone are they just re
what is this on the bottom left they're
just replaying the video over and over
no I think I think that's another I
think that's a fourth person in the call
and they just are showing a screen with
it for whatever reason oh okay okay cool
hype man [ __ ] main dude and we can I
just help the Ethan
can you still with his wife
yeah for sure for sure yeah is he trying
to make a move okay yeah I remember is
he trying to make a move on Ela yo is
your wife single but it seems like he uh
is uh somewhat of a fan well me too
it's mutual yeah he was aware of your
videos he he knows you know you were
partnered up with Ila so I love him for
that he's got dropping knowledge
I remember that my YouTube when I was
like a little kid and stuff like that
that's cool
so now
and that's kind of lit that now they're
reacting to me and stuff like that yeah
I'm sure you can come on if you want to
shout yes love hey hey what's it called
tell them I would love to do like a
little interview with
um
yes I'll be late actually and maybe a
live performance
just wait wait are they what he says are
they in Miami
um yeah so we can do a we can do a zoom
call with an interview and live
performance yeah let's get it let's get
some Island Vibes in the studio oh this
is the dream since they seem to be
interested in this I'll just say you
know I I was I was hating on you guys
um and you know it the Island Vibes
weren't weren't really clicking with me
but I can't lie it's such an ear worm
I've these guys can all test I've been
singing Island boy in the studio for the
last time yeah
yeah oh love so love is a [ __ ] he is
a true Island boy he actually is the
first person ever to transcribe the
lyrics yep yes sir did you put these
online somewhere like on on genius yeah
yeah no yes
I don't even know how to hit their
Cadence fan
you need to hear it the time signature
of the song is is actually really
Advanced we were talking about this too
that it's it's kind of progressive it's
like Progressive Island music I was
trying to Flip Flip the beat you know
out of a tune behind it but these guys
are just way too advanced it's like it's
like avant-garde Jazz almost yeah it's
like it's informed so there's five beats
and then it's like four and a half
Progressive reggae yeah it's pretty wild
oh yeah
are you like are you in the UK or in
Australia
this is the best oh my bad you get
offended
offended I don't know oh yeah you don't
be getting pressed a lot huh
[ __ ] be chilling did you know Sweden
Sweden is the country with the most
islands in the world
I I I didn't know that did we actually
touched numbers in Sweden do you know
that
what was that did we touch numbers in
Sweden touch numbers what um are they
popular like did people do people touch
numbers anywhere
about Sweden the most islands in the
world well you know it's a reflex that
he didn't really register yeah what I
think you're trying to say is that I'm
the island boy yeah and so yeah and and
commemoration of this moment
I have a the new nickname I'm the
hairline King
love
is the island King
oh my goodness the island King this is
the island yarl dude they're yarls and
in nordiculture you prefer island yarl
or Island King love
and I prefer our linking I think yeah
okay I have the choice
thank you guys thank you should I keep
watching this or do we get the the gist
oh no it's in Sweden me my brother
yeah from Tick Tock I'm sure a bunch of
people know you from the island boy oh
yeah well we got to get them on I want a
live performance I want to know
everything about them
and uh
do you want to ask him about the the ass
eating next to each other
sure I mean I don't know what's there to
task I mean the boys eat ass together
just if that makes them uncomfortable
maybe so there's like be that close to
your sibling yeah I'd like to know more
stories I'm sure apparently they had a
reputation in high school for eating ass
yeah uh we might um and so does Zach so
there's no hippie Ramen that yeah I'm
not criticizing the ass eating in of
itself it's more so the the doing the
act in such close proximity to a blood
relative that well there's Queen so you
eat ass together
here is the island King yeah [ __ ] yeah
we gotta do something about the hair
though
yeah for sure oh yeah
Island King
should we play the original just because
maybe some people don't remember yeah
it's so easy to sing along if you have
the lyrics and hear the song so let's
try it here send me the link and then
let's try to sing along here sick
yep a little cover we're dropping good
job that was such a treat
uh that that that all came together and
now we have a connection do you [ __ ] do
you have a connection with them like to
communicate now love
yeah you got the mutual follow
no they only follow 10 people so that's
kind of exclusive but you know I'm
getting there okay so you have their
email there how do you how do you
communicate with them
well Island Boys we do Instagram
Instagram DMS only
right
wait I thought you said they don't
follow you oh you do like the uh well
they're not verifying so yeah okay
someone gonna send me that link I sent
it thank you baby thank you thank you so
for anyone that missed our previous show
uh this is the island boys and I'm gonna
try to sing along here and give homage
to the Kings this is crying that's what
I'm saying absolutely it's really it's
really I'm pushing the limits
I put my best song yeah like a white
woman trying to make it to the tall but
my Island by I've been trying to make it
go ahead this next part is really
interesting if you can bring up the
lyrics on screen maybe because okay sure
I did someone send me an image
so you want to see if you got the the
transcript transcription right yeah
because this this part is really tricky
okay interesting so a see me with the
gang gang slang
you ain't just saying no Kane all right
let's let's see here we go
and lion lion from the Caribbean
hold on we gotta get this right because
we try and home like a lion yeah I think
you're right
here let's let's let's just correct that
before this is an image I can't edit
this text I'm just saying like we need
to we can't disrespect the island boys
and submit The Wrong lyrics so we need
to fix this ASAP okay for sure
[Music]
oh [ __ ] I want to see if everything else
is right
what is YouTube whoa wait what is
YouTube closed captioning like
yo they got it right rain cause we tried
home like a lion right
Island Boy from the Caribbean what is
this story they're trying to tell that's
I think that's why this song is good
because you can't understand what
they're saying because I've seen their
other [ __ ] and the words are [ __ ] I
mean but they still chose those words
you know what I mean
it's a freestyle well it's a freestyle
so it could just be way way
this is a stream of Consciousness is it
really yeah
you think this was planned yes
agree to disagree on that why no I
always thought this was a planned song I
also believe it is a freestyle I got it
I got the original videos mentions that
it's supposed to be a freestyle yeah
yeah but freestyle and rap means they
write it right
majority of rappers yeah when they say
we'll have to ask them let's ask well
the girls say this they're gonna say it
was improvised
[Music]
wait here maybe this will help you let's
watch the go this is I'm sorry to anyone
who doesn't find this interesting but
this is [ __ ] fascinating that YouTube
was able to transcribe this here all
right and I've been trying to make oh on
my Island Boy
[Music]
know that
it's pretty good
how long how long did you spend
transcribing this love
no I don't know they're Google is up to
something yeah I got another island boys
over there right I'm staying dude when I
put in love's transcription I found one
website that has it but I needed Love's
transcription to find it okay wait wait
this is we're unlocking new lyrics here
love are you watching this it's
completely different than what you wrote
like 100 different I'm I'm staying like
you want to be famous
oh boy I got a real damn tropic
that one it said islamboyant
I'm an Islam boy put on my vest
it's when the other dude is singing too
all right let's move on I think people
had enough Island Boy Shenanigans we're
actually at uh 37 minutes if you want to
go to a break we just talked like 20
minutes about Island Boys but there's
one last cherry on top could be getting
remixes now
I feel like we just owned the rights now
to the remixes we gotta just sell this
it's really good this is like the garage
two-step remix you like it Olivia I do
like it yeah oh yeah they should type as
hell dude
yes sir we have created
yeah a new market shout out to Kodiak
red and fly Soldier
shout out wait who made this remix I
should give them a shout out this was by
uh
eye Mark I Marquez here you can see his
YouTube
Marcus remix shout out to his family
um if you guys have any other
Island remixes let's keep them coming
bro
all right well
but yeah I think you showed the wrong
thing I think there's there's another
Island Boy remix that's what you just
opened wait how did I possibly open you
because there's two here I think you
open the one I don't know if you realize
that there's another Island Boy remix
already wait I opened this yes this is
the one we just listened to
[Music]
shout out to vnta look
wait so there's two remixes yeah yeah
oh [ __ ]
all right let's go to a break we'll be
right back we got a few more topics and
then we are going to get
guys if you're interested in investing
in cryptocurrencies but aren't sure
where to get started go to the kraken
app with Kraken you can buy and sell
over 50 of the most popular cryptos like
Bitcoin Dogecoin and ethereum On The Go
24 7. it's super easy to get started
just download the app create your
account and you're going to be investing
in minutes one of the coolest things
about buying crypto through the through
Kraken is that you don't need a lot of
money to try it out so even if Bitcoin
is worth 40K today it's worth over 60
man all-time high today right like 65.
you can buy as little as ten dollars
worth on Kraken just to get your feet
wet see how you like it
find out for yourself why Kraken has
been one of the highest rated places to
buy crypto for the last 10 years friend
of the show we love these guys please
support Kraken uh visit kraken.com H3
now or learn more to learn more or
search for Kraken in the app store thank
you thank you to Kraken we love you Dan
Are You Afraid of the Dark
absolutely well now you can wear
glow-in-the-dark underwear to help you
feel a little more at ease my dude yeah
it's me Andy's Halloween just dropped
just dropped dead that is
you don't want to wait for this one
because uh you're gonna get ghosted if
you don't get there in time and with
five new prints to turn up the terror
you should summon them before it's too
late guys me Andy's it's the comfiest
undies in the game I love this ship it's
soft it's breathable it's such an
upgrade on all the underwear we're used
to wearing the Haynes
comes with like 20 pairs for like two
bucks uh you know and they're all torn
up and ragged it's the same [ __ ] your
mom bought you in high school yeah you
guys know what I'm talking about uh it's
time to upgrade guys it's Time come on
this is the real deal you're gonna love
this whether you're out running a killer
or being abducted by aliens this
Halloween be comforted by the fact that
your underwears are sustainable and the
softest in town meanders are made from
natural fiber source from Beechwood
trees making their micro modal fabric
soft breathable and dangerously cozy get
your spooky Seasons up with haunting and
five new prints eyes see you my boo
Tricks and Treats the lazy bones and
lazy pumpkin available in unused
bralettes socks loungewear and sizes
extra small through 4XL and there's a
lot of options to consider
but make a decision quickly because
there's so many room behind you
uh me Andy's has got a great offer for
our listeners for any first time
purchase you get 15 off and free
shipping and they've also got a promise
for you if you're not satisfied with any
product for any reason you can return
your order for a full refund within 45
days boom risk-free baby get 50 off your
first order free shipping and 100
satisfaction guaranteed at meandies.com
H3 that's meundies.com
H3 thank you thank you what would you do
if you didn't have high interest loans
or credit card debt with upstart you can
start paying off existing debt quickly
and easily and start living your life
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating High interest debt
or funding personal expenses over a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date rather than looking at
credit scores alone upstart considers
other factors like your income current
employment and credit history to find
you a smarter rate for your loan and you
can check out your rate without
impacting your credit score too within
minutes for loans between one thousand
to fifty thousand dollars and you're
even gonna see receive your funds as
fast as one business day after accepting
your loan find out how upstart can lower
your monthly payments today when you go
to upstart.com
H3 that's upstart.com H3 don't forget to
use our URL please to let them know we
sent you loan amount will be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
App application that's upstart.com
H3 okay boys here's the deal we're just
we're going to do this segment now and
then uh I guess throw the dice on the
rest of the show afterwards as the whole
crew is blazed
so here's the deal I'm gonna walk out
Island Vibes Island Boys
a certain number but more than one
person wouldn't that be funny if we just
this was always over yeah or everybody's
High
more than one person is gonna smoke
I'm gonna bring them to my desk and
interrogate them
and see if I can figure out which one of
these guys is blazed
hey man you gotta do what you gotta do
um by the way funny thing here my our
community is the only one where they'll
post a dream blunt rotation oh my God
that doesn't include me
nobody wants to smoke with me even on my
own subreddit how is this even related
to us why does this have 800 points it's
my subreddit
and I'm not in the dream blunt rotation
that really is brutal
very sad you said you get anxious yeah I
mean anybody that's a true fan knows
that you're not into weeds so maybe
they're just taking that into account
and they don't know if these guys smoke
you think Rhett and Link Blaze
no no no no no no no no
maybe I'm just saying it you know it's
like ah come on now guys you hurt my
feelings over here that's the one that's
the the one with the long hair right uh
yes yeah I could see him being a stone
like maybe not he's a little more clean
cut well they were always until recently
very devout Christians which is why I
think no oh but they left the church
yeah
they left the church both of them yeah
really interesting the story
man okay
well at any rate I'm gonna step out now
and let the Blazing begin the audience
will not know who's High either right
yeah uh not until the reveal yeah yeah
okay so I'm gonna step outside and we'll
be right back all right welcome back so
there's a certain amount of people who
are high and I'm very
I've already have my suspicions Cameron
for example went straight to the snack
drawer laughs
fascinating yeah all right enough
Shenanigans let's get straight to the
cut to the chase here and play Guess
Who's hi
now I'm feeling like I'm gonna get a
hundred percent right I'm confident
let's start with Cam because that
motherfucker's blasted Cameron glass is
off get it get over here we're doing no
glasses no glasses okay I gotta see the
window to the soul all right cam glasses
off thank you
so first of all let me get a good look
at your face here
not too bloodshot but you got a grin on
your face that might be giving you away
you went straight for the snack drawer
were you hungry before you went outside
or yeah it's a bit of you know just
being out there worked up the appetite a
little bit you know what snack did you
grab I got a uh what was it like an
apple pie granola bar thing hmm it was
good
most sweet treat yeah how often do you
smoke
when uh pretty often I guess oh okay a
few times a week okay so that that's
interesting to know yeah here I have a
list of questions for you I'm gonna test
your aptitude here what animal do you
most identify with and why
sorry Alfredo's licking me under here uh
I got a couple
um
I like penguins because they're they
like the cold and they like the slide
around sounds like fun and I also like
ring-tailed lemurs because I like
horizontal stripes I feel like I'm
leaning more towards the uh
ringtail lemur the Lemur yeah likes that
okay you like the stripes and they also
kind of they often have like a look of
concern and anxiety on their face so how
often you look at lemurs I like to draw
them sometimes oh you draw them yeah I
mean I like to look at it okay animals
and stuff yeah
um
what superpower do you wish you had
oh man that's a tough one uh
it'd be cool to have like super strength
and stuff it'd be fun super strength why
do you want super straight
you know he's be super strong and pretty
much to say it speaks for itself right
you have fantasies about like saving
people and stuff like that I don't know
punching through walls sure why not I
think everybody wants to be a hero at
some points you know hmm yeah do you
ever
I'll ask the question all right
fair enough
okay
um let's see
tell me
um what would colors taste like what
would red taste like if you could taste
the color
probably I feel like red
I mean this is a classic one I guess red
would be a little spicy I guess you know
spicy okay interesting association with
uh how much and how much did you smoke
when you're outside not at all none
maybe okay
maybe a few Puffs okay I mean listen I
I'm not I'm on the fence you sounded
pretty confident when you called them
down yeah because for some reason when
he walked in he gave me this like this
[ __ ] eating grit and wait straight for
the snacks
and then I was like you're definitely
high and he gave me a look like what
makes you think I mean I know you're
asking the questions but what makes you
go on the fence now about it do I seem
Lucid do I seem
uh coherent yeah okay more but I don't
know how much you guys smoked is it like
is would it be enough to blast someone
or are we talking like a subtle nice
high like if you compare this to how
high you get at home how would this
compare
this is a loaded question
okay okay
I mean I feel like I've got a fairly
decent tolerance you know I'm not like
the an iron lung but you know I'm okay
Middle Ground okay all right
ah so I got a guess you gotta make a
verdict
all right well I would say if you are
high you performed well awesome
that being said
I think you're high
okay lock in that answer
you got that idea we'll reveal it at the
end at the end I'm gonna be so what do
you think about my guess
I I think I'll have to wait and find out
he's pretty slick he didn't let me trip
him up on stuff
did you feel Shady out there in the
alleyway
did I feel Shady no I mean it felt at
home out there in the alleyway okay
interesting bro are you [ __ ] high
right now yeah all right thank you Cam
thank you all right good performance
either way solid performance but I don't
know something tells me this man is high
Something tells me
okay
AB get over here let's see
oh he's scared of Shredder he's he's
more scared of Shredder than usual
foreign
you seemed a little startled by Shredder
lunging at you there it's because I'm
high no I'm playing
um how often do you smoke I don't maybe
once a year and then I always regret it
oh
okay remember he's he's told stories on
the show before so you're like me yeah
the infamous Bongo story correct was one
of them yeah so you could be having what
you I mean if you smoke today you could
be having probably a bad you'd be having
one another story to tell it's a
horrible moment right Vietnam flashbacks
did you feel Shady out there smoking in
the hallway uh a little bit yeah it was
a little surreal though could be smoking
with H3 crew so yeah I think my simpness
was covering up use you were aware of
how cool it was correct with legendary
Crews such as Dan mm-hmm
it's a high thought
or a simp thought
yeah
um
[Music]
what's your greatest phobia and why is
it being high on the on today's free
podcast this right now yeah I'm playing
um
I don't know greatest phobia
dying without putting out any videos
that sounds cheesy but that's my biggest
fear dying without putting out videos
yeah just like making stuff like making
short films or things like that because
I
I don't know
I'm very critical of myself and I like
making videos I have since I was a kid
even if it's just for fun and I never
end up putting stuff out your passion is
making videos yes and if I die before I
actually like you already put out videos
but not like more videos not like
YouTube videos I mean like you know
short projects that I'm proud of just
keep it going yeah
hmm
and does that mean that this work is not
fulfilling enough for you are you
planning on
now that this work is very fulfilling
for me it's a side thing it's not for
this is a side thing no my videos are a
side thing it's not to live off of or
anything like that it's just something I
like doing I don't play video games so
except except Donkey Kong so Donkey Kong
yes
that might have scared him off it
interesting and do we have the drums can
we bring him the drums the Bongos yeah
they're his personal I think they're at
home they're at home yeah I burned them
after that episode
all right um let's see here what is your
guilty pleasure
guilty pleasure I like Celine Dion
Celine Dion she did uh
that one
what's your favorite album of hers
um
I don't know I don't know her albums to
be honest so why is she your guilty
pleasure it's just I don't know I went
to her concert once because my wife's
uncle gave us free tickets and that [ __ ]
hit me I don't know I felt it
here's Celine Dion Oh it's just
self-titled
that one
that's my favorite
wait what the [ __ ] what is this story
are you high bro all right I'm gonna
take I'm gonna again it's a tough one
eyes look fine
but I don't know if I'm just I'm on the
I feel like everybody's hot hmm
I feel like everybody's high it's a
paranoid thought Ethan maybe you're high
I'm not high
what's five times five times four five
times five twenty five times four is a
hundred
minus 73.
27.
plus five
[Applause]
32.
minus seven
this [ __ ] is high dude come on I
don't even remember the numbers what are
the numbers I'm just doing good on that
oh yeah it was like five questions in a
row you lost me come on if you're sober
that's easy
I'm stupid
how do you feel now
is being stupid a protect the class now
yeah
according to that video that's it I'm
locking it in you're walking in the
answer yeah all right answer locked
and you got can I just ask a question
are all of you high you can't ask a
question no I feel like you guys would
do that [ __ ] to me where everybody no we
didn't do that to you okay or did we and
I believe there's different levels of
blazed
somebody ripped harder I feel like a
couple may have
ah
a couple or a few
what are these meta questions all right
Dan get over here you're breaking the
rules Dan tough guy Dan ladies and
gentlemen
I'm gonna come so Dan is I feel like Dan
is the responsible one way he'll be like
I'm not gonna get high during the show
because someone has to be here and we
were on our way out Dan goes okay but
just one he's telling everybody if
you're high just make sure if you're the
one just don't hit it too hard because
we have a show to do so it's true but
yeah all that together of all the people
here I feel like you could keep it
together the most under influence there
is that X Factor isn't there does your
mouth dry my mouth is always dry really
yeah it's kind of like a consistent
problem probably from smoking it's dry
when you're not smoking yeah it just
that's why I'm drinking water constantly
and we all drink water dancing
pre-workers it for life okay
that's true see I feel like Dan's high
too this is Dan's water he always has
this by him just so you know we're all
drinking water man it doesn't mean [ __ ]
that's true
how long you've been smoking
since I was like 15 or something never
stopped no I mean for some periods of
time here and there but I would say
pretty consistently since that age and
are you in like a heavy usage
no not right now no no I'd still smoke
every day that's right still smoke
pretty consistently but definitely not
like when I was in my 20s
I see that was an everyday smoker for a
long time you don't smoke every day no
no like a weekend thing or like a week
mostly weekends sometimes during the
week I don't know three kind of like
what Cam said probably like two to three
times a week something like that
I know I can't say everybody's high but
it's like Dan's High I gotta stop I
gotta stop saying everyone's High
dan t what's five times three plus five
fifteen twenty
times five a hundred minus fifty plus
three fifty times three
53 times three uh
159 okay
checks out checks out
if you can live in a cartoon which
cartoon would you be
and
in a cartoon well
see
where my mind immediately goes the
cartoons that I think of
wouldn't actually be that enjoyable to
be in you know like dystopian the
settings or so yeah I wouldn't really
want to be in the world of Berserk yeah
uh so I would have to go with something
kind of wholesome I don't know I guess
world of can I just be in like the world
of Looney Tunes like I mean a [ __ ]
hell yeah
not one of the old racist ones no
definitely not one of those okay
just checking one of the more wholesome
uh you know duck season rabbit season
let's see because when Looney Tunes was
pretty violent you think Wiley Coyote
but it's so cartoon it's like it's like
in Roger Rabbit you know you just turn
into a pancake and then you can like pop
right back up it's all good
or maybe let's say um
you know being nice Totoro a Miyazaki
movie told her that was a beautiful
place yeah it's just like nice kind of
thing
and you got like really nice little
Forest Spirits coming along and who who
Kappa seems like really soft too so
who's in your nightmare blunt rotation
my nightmare one rotation uh oh [ __ ]
I mean I I guess Henry Kissinger
all right Dan you're sober get out of
here Henry Kissinger
dance over I gotta do it on something I
feel like he's high in my heart of
hearts but I'm gonna say sober
foreign
this is hard
I will know he did trip on the way back
to his seat
he made me already locked in your answer
though
you're [ __ ] high bro I knew it you
knew it because I tripped I've been
actually a trip I just kicked one of the
wires on the way back
Olivia you want to come over here
Olivia ladies and gentlemen Olivia
everybody
I love you everybody are you a frequent
smoker Olivia
yeah yeah sometimes a week okay okay wow
a bunch of bless potheads here that
makes sense tell me let's tell the
people about yourself your new crew
member uh so you have a lot of fans
people are very nice to me yeah
I am 22. mm-hmm I'm from Los Angeles
shout out
big fan of the H3 podcast pound it
what's up
uh send emails did you know this I sent
emails for like a full year to the
podcast email and then I didn't yeah I
did did you guys know that I actually
didn't know
I sent Zach an email but he always talks
about he has no idea how I found his
personal email wait how'd you find it it
was linked in his Instagram but he says
it wasn't well how'd she find it then
Zach how would I find it dude I don't
know
well you clearly did have it in your
Instagram never once I I've always had
my work email but never my personal
interesting I think you're wrong she got
it somehow yeah you're smoking dude
or not
do your parents know you smoke they do
okay
interesting
uh
um tell me who is in your nightmare
blunt rotation
do I just name a bunch of people I hate
yeah okay
oh for sure James is it mine
James is on my Hit List oh [ __ ] I was a
big fan you were a fan I was a fan of
everybody and then they turned out to be
terrible people you were a fan of James
you're a fan of Shane were you a fan of
Jeffrey
not as much huge fan of Trisha right we
all were yeah Sam was too man yeah
but those people I would say I don't
want to hurt any feelings yeah I doubt
James is gonna see this so that's okay
is your mouth dry my mouth is always dry
that's [ __ ] boy when I get nervous I
promise all of our mouths are dry all
the time
literally impounding no no no in water
all day when I get nervous my ears get
really warm and my mouth gets really dry
you're nervous right now yes you are
okay I think Olivia's sober I'm gonna
give you a pass all right
but I think your highest but under okay
like I think you're high underneath but
I'm gonna give you a pass so I'm gonna
say You're Sober I think you're all hot
thank you I hope so
I feel like ah watch your step on that
cable
Dan's warning everybody
okay
interesting
I feel like you guys didn't smoke enough
I wanted bong grips and dabs
I can
I can't handle the dabs I've done it
like twice in my life and horrible like
the way that you describe your
experiences where you feel just beyond
that that's what happens to me yeah it's
like the bong grips when I that like is
enough to put you in like paralysis for
a week and then they're like no we need
to go beyond that yeah dabs it's crazy
all right Zach come over here you've
been talking a lot of uh [ __ ] you've
been heckling glasses off come on cool
guy he put his glasses on to come sit
right now
glasses off Hey listen um
Zach you're such a character bro
I love you I love you too did you see
that post on the subreddit about how you
are the kind of guy to sleep with some
kid's mom and call him Kiwa Saba on the
way out what was it
yeah that's pretty funny I do someone
pulled that Meme up because yeah it had
like seven thousand points I do have a
kimono like that so I mean like I figure
like it would be in a kimono or
something you know for sure yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um is it hot in here
look at this photo the F oh it has ten
thousand points look at that photo look
at all the awards Zach is the type of
guy to have casual sex with a 42 year
old woman and then come into the kitchen
the next morning wearing one of her
robes and refer to her tween age son as
Kimo Sabe as he grabs him OJ
look at that photo dude you're a unit
bro
what do you think about that
it's funny man what can I say do you
smoke a lot no not really no no you
strike me as one such how often do you
smoke
maybe once a two weeks once a month oh
okay yeah
you dabble yeah I dabble what's your
favorite like drug do you drink drug
nicotine
nicotine right right is your mouth dry
right now I mean yeah like everyone else
so yeah somehow everybody's got dry
mouth here
he's a smoker he has the best excuse out
of everybody
in Minecraft
so so let me ask you what happened yeah
what's up would you rather have dinner
why uh who's your favorite like living
person ever
Ethan Klein is it really no it's not
tell me who's your favorite person
oh [ __ ]
um
that's a tough one man favorite musician
oh that's another okay what's your guy
uh what's who's the guitar guy the Van
Halen oh yeah would you rather have
dinner with Van Halen rip to the goat or
a million dollars
probably dinner with Eddie really come
any Rolexes you could have no I didn't
know that he would be cool that'd be
really cool more than a million yeah
what if he doesn't even like you so risk
I'm willing to take
I'm in the same room as Eddie Van
Halen's huh
yeah
it's like really hot in here dude yeah
no you think it's hotter here than it
was at your time yeah I'm in the hot
seat right now
your eyes look like hamburger
uh do you feel different do you feel
nervous no you feel okay it's
loosey-goosey baby it's all love right
Celine Dion why are we showing Celine
Dion I love something A New Day Has Come
Love Celine um is hot dog a sandwich
no
I thought why is hot dog not a sandwich
it's like in a a bun with a bottom right
like it's like kind of the bottom seals
yeah also I'm making a bold statement if
you put ketchup on your hot dog there's
something wrong with you what that's a
lot of people what is this take there's
something wrong that's not Chicago
right there
pickle onion okay none of the ketchup
[ __ ]
okay Zach you sit on people's grass
yeah and I'm [ __ ] on their hot dog
too
yeah you are that's not in the recipe
you just said [ __ ] y'all okay
um
so when you sit on the lawn that one
time did you like was your ass or was
there lots of [ __ ] in your in your
butthole yeah but um
um
retail what's what's 20 times eight I'm
not doing math 20 times eight right now
I [ __ ] failed math five plus ten uh
fifteen times five thirty
attempts fifteen is thirty times fifteen
yeah oh [ __ ] let me look at my clock
real quick
fifty five times fifteen is fifty yeah
oh I don't know dude inshallah I don't
know
you're sweating right now yeah I think
that's high get out of here
[ __ ] five times fifteen ass [ __ ]
50. get out of here
musicians aren't
don't tend to you know five times
fifteen is fifty what are you doing with
the extra five well yeah didn't you say
30. you said 50 50. okay yeah
he was sweating man I saw the sweat
coming down his brow
sacia so my face was always red
yeah it's more red than usual you're
dude you're legit like it's so hot in
here yeah you're sweating balls
all right well hold I gotta so I've got
how many highs here I've already said
three people are high you said I am high
and Cameron's high and Zach is I Olivia
and Dan are sober oh my God I feel like
I'm getting everything wrong hmm
well you have uh both Sam and Ian left
to do okay uh Sam
come on down
Sam's High
I haven't even sat down
Sam Sam Sam Samantha
Sam is that your full name though oh
yeah Samantha is yeah got it
do you smoke a lot no
no you don't
never is your mouth dry right now
no not really okay interesting
what if this is for me I got something
here it is a picture of Sonic the
Hedgehog does this mean anything to you
up
flashbacks this is traumatic the Sonic
movie
[Music]
what does this mean to you
I'm having PTSD right now
he's
did you um are you uh what do you want
for lunch
I want in and out so bad
we can make that happen and now canceled
yeah what are you gonna order
the double the double cheese French
cheese pickles onions not grilled I like
it fresh too animal style fries
Sam you're high as [ __ ]
if you think that
what's what does this mean to you
this is this is [ __ ] up is it high
right here is it high here or or um was
it just that is it hot here I mean it's
hot it's like I'm burning up right here
and um
and um like when you got when you were
high during the Sonic movie well how did
it how did did it feel anything like
this or it's just more mellow it's
starting to feel like this yeah
I don't like it all right Sam thank you
Sam is high for sure I'm calling it and
we are going to be getting in and out so
the only one left is Ian right that's
right all right come out here Ian Mr
Slater
[Music]
oh
Ian Slater yeah
[Applause]
he's got his own song and everything
Pian Ian
you got any Antics planned no no antics
okay no
like no no no no like Sam you are
exhibit a what does this mean to you sir
look at it look it's pain it's pain so
you don't smoke when was the last time
you smoked was it the Sonic movie okay
well
uh when we first started coming up with
this segment um
out of curiosity because I don't smoke
ever I thought let me gauge a little to
see how I handle
weed yeah because I'm not used to it and
I took a couple hits the other day uh
this was maybe two two weeks ago
and I remember I I was in the bathroom
for what felt like like three hours but
then I came out and Sam was like you're
in there like 10 minutes
and and I I remember saying to her I go
I think this is what our cat feels like
and how much did you smoke I took a good
like like seven or eight like oh that's
a lot yeah so how much did you smoke
today
how many puffs you're not putting me in
that Pitfall my friend
not today
seven or eight Puffs huh that's a pretty
hearty hit I was I was feeling the vibe
man are you feeling the vibe today
is it hot there or what what's everyone
complaining no I don't think it's that
hot here to be honest yeah
are you hungry
I'm a little hungry a little peckish
yeah I'm a little pecky what are you
into in and out or uh Shake Shack well
after that
I'm conflicted on the internet but I
don't like Shake Shack hi
it's very greasy I mean I'll say that it
doesn't hit the same
I like In-N-Out but their fries are such
a disappointment you agree the fries are
a little boring yep
if the Earth were a Sim game what would
you change first can you repeat that
what's five times three
15 10 plus 10 25
times seven
uh it's uh 175.
25 times seven yeah
yeah it's 175.
Ian silver he's sober that's it we can
die oh no no no excuse me you locked it
in no no I'm not locked in sit back sit
down
if you try and imagine a color that
doesn't exist
what is it can you imagine a color that
doesn't exist
I mean that's hard that's a big ask why
why is it hard
like I just well
hmm like what it's called should I call
it give it a name no why is it hard
because they exist they all exist okay
fair enough
but if I were to make a new one I'd call
it like
Shuffle
Shuffle
okay they're related to purple at all no
it's more of like a it feels like a
purple to me like a purple variant I'm
getting kind of like a limeish blue are
you going to uh dinner tonight
yeah I think so
okay cool because I'll still see you
there yeah yeah you'll be there we're
all going tonight
I don't remember that open invite ah
testing I'm [ __ ] with you did you
feel Shady outside smoking nah it's cool
out there I don't know I feel like Ian
sober but I feel like I'm being tricked
by everyone as well but I think you're
sober Ian all right compared to your
other high stories it sounds like you're
losing your mind
locked in Ian ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
it's time for the Moment of Truth
so
let's start from the top
um Dan I said you were not high right
that is what you said
Dan was capable of doing math on the Fly
he seemed like relatively fine I had a
hunch that he might be high but
ultimately
Dan were you high or sober
hi baby let's go I knew it that's [ __ ]
up
how much did you smoke
I probably smoked the most out of
anybody here tell my truth well it was a
joint but I got it started and then it
kept going out and I was doing some some
surgery on it so I don't know I probably
puffed it like
eight times and how do you feel like in
terms of your highness level very
moderate that's that's not how am I
supposed to get when this guy's moderate
out there I need this guy blasted out of
his mind I need him dabbing to Heaven I
think if anybody else had smoked as much
as I did they would be pretty blasted to
have it flexed I'm just my reflex it's
not even a flex it's just
just is what it is
for legal releases right now dude look
at his eyes he's lit
all right so one down I had a feeling I
was like
I mean you wanted to say everybody was
happy I know but I had a specific
feeling about you because you were like
you tripped on that [ __ ] goofy ass I'm
just a goofy ass I don't know and then
also we said rolling
I remember there was something High
where we said rolling and you said are
we going and I said we're like no not
yet
and I was like he's high
well that's because I think the video we
had on his PC instead of rolling the
recording yeah you said rolling the
video I was like dude we always mean
rolling recording true true okay what
well one wrong Olivia
seemed fine to me she is a regular
smoker did I say you were sober you did
okay Olivia reveal the truth to us
you're wrong oh my God you guys didn't
smoke enough it's not my fault I would
argue that I actually did smoke a lot
yeah I think Olivia and I probably hit
it at the moment because I also hit a
pen well yeah well and so how are you
feeling like on the high meter right now
I'm pretty I'm pretty sure yeah
do I gather that much I think he kept it
together really well it's hard to tell
because I couldn't tell if people were
just nervous to be on camera right in
the hot seat or if they were
what whenever I get high I
um will say something and then it'll
echo in my head like 10 times as loud or
as like extravagant as I had done it and
it's happening literally as I speak but
you seem fine right now that's just not
how I'm perceiving myself though you
know damn it
I could have just screamed all of that
and I believe I should have just gone
with the people that like I that are
regular smokers well there was a lot of
thought put into this of yeah you guys
who would and who wouldn't and there was
some gamesmanship going on because in my
if I was on your side I would just say
there's no way I'm smoking on the show
period it's not happening right well and
you kind of followed the you fell right
into our trap I gotta say well at least
with what you were saying about me
because you were like you seem
responsible like even though you smoke
all the time it seems like in this
situation you would you know want to
keep it together and that was pretty
much our thought process we were like
Ethan's gonna expect Dan to be high but
then he'll think he won't be because
he's wow 5D chess over here fool me all
right AB
who's had dramatic weed experiences you
would expect him to say hell no I'm not
doing it for the show which is what I
would do if I was in his shoes get so
something seemed off he was unable to do
basic arithmetic
in my defense it was like Fast
multiplication for me but for Dan the
smartest guy in the office you're like
what's 15 plus five I'm like what the
[ __ ] you're a smart guy I tossed all
kinds of numbers I mixed it up so I'm
easy some hard
I'm no Dan what you you're snacking at
this moment you don't usually eat on
camera okay baby are you high
important yes I got one you did indeed
you're doing pretty good surprisingly
because um
I smoked a lot I don't know why
okay finally I got one right well good
for you for coming out on the show and
get and getting litty my my titty
[Laughter]
all right so here we go
oh yeah what about cam
you call him over yeah cam come on cam
uh come on down come on down
so I said cam was high right you did
yeah
cam regular smoker I had a feeling this
guy was high when he came out just
immediately it was just all over his
face oh yeah
but I could be wrong so far everybody's
been high so I don't know if this is the
everyone should not it's a guy that's
the [ __ ] cam are you are you high yes or
no I am
sober as a judge right now yeah
which judge Judge Judy damn fine judge
Klein God I'm horrible at This I Swear
when I walked in cam I don't know if
you're trying to pretend like you are
but you were staring at me with a grand
I I think it's just that I'm nervous to
be right next to you in the hot seat
there and I'm just I have a Dopey smile
I think I'm just too my Spidey senses
are too tingly
and I'm just missing everywhere well
kamek Zoo's Stoner energy though I think
they love I don't even I think that's
totally fair to say yeah so did you
smoke yesterday
uh no but the day before that so
technically I'm right it takes THC seven
days all right judge Klein all right
thank you gg gg
no re okay so I've got one out of four
right I am terrible at this hopefully
people watching are better
or Sam I'm dying to know him Sam come on
down
Sam I need in and out
you're high come on just tell me the
truth
I must confess I I am high yeah I got
another one I would say you and a b
definitely were the uh my favorite Hot
Seat guests I was about to have a panic
attack up there I was I was worried it's
because of Sonic I don't I I never smoke
and I was so scared to smoke uh sativa
how do you feel now you're okay
I had to go like
I'm not gonna lie I went and I sat on
the floor in the bathroom for a second
oh that's what I was saying I was like I
choose having a panic attack in the
bathroom I went over I was like hey how
you doing she's like I gotta throw up oh
you still want the burgers though yes
okay good yes I don't want to make I
don't want you to lose your appetite
well thank you for doing that for the
show
fantastic showing imagine you held it
together pretty good I mean I wasn't
totally sure
the candy woman
thank you Sam great job
I could tell she was high when she
started talking about in and out she was
so passionate she got lost in the burger
description yeah yeah
that was the calmest I've ever been up
there
yeah he said some stupid [ __ ] but I felt
calm
a new Stoner is born
hell yeah hell yeah brother oh yeah
brother all right so
um up next we've got Zach come on down
Zach so hold on there's just one sober
person
so far
just Cameron
all right Zacky let's see keep us
kiwasabi give us hobby my dude
Zach has always on something I feel like
Zach is just too much of a character to
pin down
I'm high on life dude
and are you also high on THC I am
I got that one right yeah
foreign
when I first I took about three tokes
and when I first did it I'm like started
to feel the anxiety attack come on
like when we were outside and I'm like
oh [ __ ] this is not gonna be good but
then I started to mellow out so it's
it's all great you did great in the
season it's all good baby
I could tell though yeah it's it's uh
people already think I'm always high
because I'm just so giggly but yeah I'm
hot right now are you you might have
said I am weed and when I asked you if
you're high sure we could go with that
well done and finally we have Ian
I guess Ian's sober
I'm sober man okay
ah you would have really fooled me
because I was like is this guy high or
what's going on but I'm glad I got that
one right because that would have really
surprised me
well we we based on your previous
experiences we had all these questions
to kind of and then you made this new
meta of like just mathematician over
here yeah it's hard hard to navigate
that one that sucked me up dude yeah
gotta get into those heads horrible at
math
so that's it that's no that's no excuse
for getting five saying five times
fifteen is fifty I was in remedial math
yeah I don't know if the the weed was
necessarily a factor let's just call
stupidity right there but stupidity but
you know math is hard for some people
I'll tell you what times five times
fifty well you know 15 or was it yeah
wasn't it five times fifteen sorry well
you know it's at least 50 because you
know what five times ten is Right 50
yeah and so you have an extra five 55
okay let's move on I Can't Drive 55 man
but I'm okay you're good
it's uh yeah
I don't believe me blame my [ __ ]
Elementary School teachers man
what's her name I'm kidding I'm kidding
anyway you guys did great so what was
the final score
uh you got four correct and three wrong
and not bad
but what's interesting is there's only
two sober people mm-hmm
[Music]
so I was kind of right everybody was
high
that's not everybody no but except Zach
and cam will cam trick the [ __ ] out of
me Ian and Ken
yeah I mean he in a camp are you accept
something
all right let's see how the rest of this
show goes with all with everyone please
no they're mine
wow great job guys thank you thank you
[Applause]
shout out to the island man Rasta pirate
rust the pirate lion
bigger bigger bigger booyah
I smoke two joints in the morning
I smoked two joints at night
thank you this races is it I don't know
I
shout out for the island maybe a little
bit
when people mattered chat for for doing
that well I'm making fun of chat I agree
and like I'm not out there like
making Jamaican my identity yeah I'm not
trans racial
I'm not trans racial yeah okay fair
enough
well Jack's the one playing Jamaican
music I wouldn't know what to do if I
got it
and you were you were singing Sublime
which uh is definitely they're kind of
like no that's a Bob Marley Dan
correction it is a Bob Marley song what
the hell is wrong with two joints yeah
it's Bob Marley you really think Sublime
wrote that you want that well listen I
know it's I know it's a cover but I
don't think it's a Bob Marley cover you
wanna bet oh my God you're gonna
question Zacks it's definitely a Bob
Marley cover and even I know that and I
don't know [ __ ] about music
who won uh Rock history here Dan
okay wasabi
uh Smoke Two Joints is a song originally
written by the toys
yeah made Popular by Bob Marley
oh so he also did a cover so it's not a
Bob Marley song well I mean it's not a
Sublime song
the article
never mind
just enjoy the vibe guys no no no no the
vibe is killed Maybe
this song is optimistically attributed
to Bob Marley over the internet but yeah
but you know who didn't write it
Sublime [ __ ] 90s listen
yeah I'm sorry you guys are both
completely wrong Marley had been dead
for two years when this song was written
bro there is no Bob Marley okay fine
I'll still release the songs man wait
what we're all wrong man well listen I
knew it was a cover but I knew it wasn't
a Bob Marley's
go ahead Zach actually yeah are you
[ __ ] higher I think I am [ __ ]
hiring I think the song was originally
released in 1983 he died in 81.
there's no Bob Marley version of that
song There is no it says the song was
often mistakenly attributed to Bob
Marley on internet and file sharing
websites so like it's been a
long-running like Urban or
misunderstanding oh it was mislabeled
when we were downloaded on LimeWire yeah
Napster well I apologize for that one
man wow that must be wise I know myself
you said it was Sublime so well listen
you gotta pass the blame around
most people like you and I who grew up
in Southern California know that song
from endlessly being played on the radio
the sublime version so it it was a fair
assumption no I heard well did I
misattribute it because of LimeWire or
did I hear it on the radio you were
right it's a cover it's not a Sublime
song you were right it's just it's not a
bummer
okay you know what I was thinking about
crushing the mods you know you know what
I was thinking of I was thinking I Shot
the Sheriff that's a Bob Marley song
that's right
[ __ ] on your lawn but but I did not poop
in my car
what's your favorite uh Bob Marley album
Zach me uh probably catch a fire same
bro hell yeah bro
let's go camera [ __ ] on my neighbor's
lawn
but I did not poop in the toilet
could this just be the whole show
the rails
just look at Zach he's so blazed right
now
for real though everybody go listen to
Catching Fire great album great album
fantastic
his first right if I'm not mistaken I
don't think it was the first no okay
guys this is a music trivia [ __ ]
recommend your favorite music time
it was definitely an early album though
yeah
Peter Tosh was still in there can we do
a show please rip to the goat my dude
there's tragic death guys didn't Michael
Jackson cover I Shot the Sheriff or was
it Bob Marley first oh Eric Clapton not
Michael Jackson guys we have an agenda
here we have a show on the document come
on let's go
you're right let's talk about Ron
Kavanaugh
wait let's do it because this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] great thank you Dan turn the
gray is the turn the reggae down
we can have another reggae moment in a
little bit okay you guys can recommend
your favorite tunes and stuff
we have important information
about this man if you see this man he is
wanted no I'm just kidding
actually he is wanted for
we want him to drop the lawsuit yeah
he's he is wanted for I can't get my
finger right
and who's High I can't point my feet are
right wait go back
I think you might have got a little
contact yeah this guy it's kind of
flipped I was like
bring it back
name your favorite Bob Marley song quick
okay Exodus Sublime uh Sublime
all right cut the music
you play the music
I was a little Lila boy
from the land of Jamaica
when I saw a grassy place I pulled down
my pants
and took a steamy dump
then I lit the Smoky joint oh
it made me want to poop again
[Music]
okay enough
[Music]
is that racist that was very impressive
that was very good
I think you're hot if you think that was
good
all right so
Emily D Baker more like Emily D baked yo
you know
oh exactly [ __ ] out there horn yeah this
show is not going anywhere
I feel like I'm high just from being
around you guys all right thank you so
Emily D Baker made a response to um
trailer responded to our motion this
whole thing is so stupid we we made a
motion to dismiss and then they
responded and then we just posted a new
response today but their response of
course is brilliant as always
Emily D baked uh
shout out to her friend of the show we
love her made a little she made a very
long video about it going over it but we
did a super cut
of her reacting to some of the finer
points of their
uh response to our motion so here it is
for your enjoyment free this [ __ ] gets
triller is a privately held company cool
triller became aware of a inversion
issue
trailer admit that it's flipped is that
what's about to happen it is what
happened what's happening I'm so
confused they had they included a sworn
testimony from their Chief attorney
and he said there was an inversion issue
on the dates from this to this and I was
like you all just tried to sue me for
saying your [ __ ] was flipped yeah you
just said your [ __ ] yeah it was flipped
you had an immersion it flipped your
[ __ ] [ __ ] is flipped you literally
just put it in a sworn testimony
what the [ __ ]
incredible
um this lasted 30 times longer than the
fight was yeah and more entertaining I
would proffer
it's my opinion oh I think triller
admits that it's flipped
on or about July 7th 2021 triller became
aware of an inversion issue
yeah your [ __ ] is flipped
vertices done defense yo triller my
things inverted
oh my God I'm dying I can't I can't
I can't I just y'all I was look I looked
I looked at the the chart that's coming
up I did not
look at this I was not I was not
prepared
I was not prepared I was not prepared
it's not flipped it's inverted uploaded
tick tocks if you find something
interesting from a reposted Tick Tock
you have to leave the app go to tick
tock search the username find the video
you just watched hunt for a follow-up
it's absolute trash I would not
recommend this app to my enemy waste of
time space on my phone and resources
imagine trying to make a knockoff app
and putting money into it how do you
prove that that person is a fan of the
H3 podcast yeah so I will get to this
they pulled they've included in their
complaint 200
pages of one star reviews that they got
and they're saying that we have driven
all of these look how long this
complaint is you guys look at this
literally 200 Pages here at the bottom
it says seven eight look at this look at
this these are all one star reviews
that their app got and they're saying
that it's all my fault that that they
got all these one star reviews but they
admit themselves the [ __ ] was flipped
maybe somebody left a review because
their app is unusable flipped trash
like God forbid somebody has a bad
experience on this [ __ ] app and it's
my fault uh it's so awkward look at this
I'm only on page 50 of 200 now they
included all of this for the judge to
read apparently here let's just read one
at random let's see oh I'm gonna have to
open the document
but the amount of work they put into
this is embarrassing or maybe they maybe
have a way of pulling it and just
pasting it I don't know yeah probably
spreadsheet they were able to export or
something yeah I mean I mean we were
skimming through it and we were seeing a
lot that were just like just general
generic like this is a tick tock rip-off
one star yeah I was like bro that that's
a commonly held um opinion yep and like
if you guys want to go and give it a one
star review that's your prerogative
I mean rated whatever your heart tells
you it could be one
or five stars I mean I personally
wouldn't want to use an app that was
just a rip up of tick tock that'd be a
one star for me flipped and I would
leave a review and I did right
personally speaking that's fair and they
go oh they're laughing and snickering no
laughter I'm saying this I'm serious as
a [ __ ] artist I'm saying the stone
cold sober right now you're saying it's
stoned
that was the joke
okay wait no I have to save some
straight face because otherwise they'll
add to the complaint that I was laughing
right which proves
that I'm trying to get everyone to go
give them one star
give it a one star review right now if
that's what you think this app deserves
I gave it a one star because I don't
like the app and frankly I don't like
the owner that's enough reason to give
it a one star this guy is a public forum
it's like it's not that serious you know
people can have their opinions about
your app man sorry bro you're in the
public space welcome to America First
Amendment [ __ ]
free speech for me but not for the
yeah we're only halfway through do you
see all these complaints it's insane
they literally put this all in a [ __ ]
motion bro this is like the the silliest
[ __ ] I've ever seen so I want to pull
from it and read some
that is a legitimate criticism
the app is all re-uploaded tick tocks
and it's annoying
was accused by his ex-partner of running
upon anything anything else you want to
put on my lap your your marriage fell
apart is that my fault too Ryan how many
divorces you on now you want to put them
all on me
where the DUI is your fault
two DUIs where I am those are both my
fault
what else
being sued by your Nanny was it me that
forced you not to pay her Ryan
this [ __ ] guy hard hard pass fam
again that was a news article forging a
document accusing his ex-president of
sexual assault so he didn't have to pay
him
um
alleged perseverance
um allegedly
I'm too high to correct you so yeah
allegedly
I believe that's well that's what the
judge said yeah the judge at one point
said that yes yeah so I'm just I'm
paraphrasing what the judge said [ __ ]
fraudulent same with the Ponzi scheme
that's what variety said later retracted
right they did they did retract elements
of that story
how do you prove where they heard the
news article from how do you prove this
to a jury we're too high for this [ __ ]
by our lawyer
[Music]
av's usually the appointment on this he
goes uh I'm I'm out send someone in the
in the fourth quarter
is that what they say
yeah I think so
what sport are you referring to maybe
she sends someone else saying I'm gonna
put me on the bench okay
what's your what sport are we doing
uh basketball
have halves I think
not headquarters
oh they do okay orders oh okay sorry I'm
just exposed by myself
just a complete Tick Tock rip-off but
without the entertainment no one's on
there it's a dead app also I heard the
owner is Accused by his ex-partner of
running a ponzi's team and I'm not about
to say yeah that's written by variety on
a behavior
um yeah somebody's gonna be like yeah I
heard he also sold lularoe it's a joke
that's not a joke variety did write an
article about how he was accused by his
ex-partner running Ponzi scheme but
anyway let's open the complaint because
they're desperate to prove that all of
these reviews
they are desperate for us to read these
bad reviews apparently which is what
we're gonna do
basically that's what they've achieved I
mean it's a public filing so I have
every right I don't know how do I do I
have to download it Dan like it's so
small
oh yeah probably they're Court dock
Google drives a PDF viewers not very
good shit's flipped dude shit's flip so
it's pretty big for a [ __ ] PDF
because he's got like 200 Pages yeah
right
all right let's try this again
I come from the island man
I leave one star review on the trailer
page
four five Brian Cavanaugh
if you come to the island and smoke if
you come to the island and get drunk you
go to jail
no we don't like drunk driving
let's think of how to dig ourselves out
of this we just smoke weed and be happy
every day
but if you come to the island and get
drunk and drive
[Music]
you go straight to jail I don't know
sorry apologies oh no my partner no
scheme no partner no scheme oh yeah
how'd that go um
I remember I remember remember coming
from the ponzis town
looking for a partner to scheme
I couldn't find me no partner no partner
no scheme
then I picked up a bottle of rum
and I tricked myself silly
[Music]
then I got in my car drove his trunk and
got pulled over my name is Ryan Kavanagh
two DUIs at my doorstep there you go
who is at my doorstep Lord no no please
no alcohol no Drive
no
no I drive
Drive I uh my president come to me and
say
please can I have a raise
I said well my my company's going
bankrupt
so I falsely accuse you of sexual
assault harassment
no lying under oath
hey
this is the at The Life and Times of
Ryan Cavanaugh
good luck putting that in a complaint RV
Weinstein
he looked I looked they say I look like
Harvey Weinstein but he's just a bloke
to me
no Ponzi no scheme
they say I look like Harvey Weinstein
but that don't mean nothing
no Ponzi no scheme
[Music]
you know what's the difference between
Ryan Kavanaugh and Harvey Weinstein
one's in jail one soon to be in jail
for financial things not sexual things
to be very clear
oh wait which one's Ryan and which one's
Harvey
uh the one on the right is Harvey the
one on the left is Ryan are you serious
yeah wow
Harvey is not Asian well at all in
prison prison has been hard on Harvey
man and Ryan he's falling apart
do you see it
yeah I'm just imagining to add this
complaint on screen they put a picture
of an orc and a picture of Harvey
Weinstein alleging that Ryan was the
Harvey Weinstein the orc is Harvey
Weinstein your honor
defamation
all right let's read some bad reviews
here's the first one out of like 10 000.
I had this app once and it was garbage
recently heard they flipped it since
then dumpster fire app Straight Out The
Gate that could be anyone for any
[ __ ] reason
[Music]
right yeah
what the [ __ ] season your
yes you know what's interesting in their
um
breakdown of why
um it was flipped they specifically say
it was flipped on iOS devices where many
of these complaints were from Android
users and therefore could not have
experienced the bug like they were
trying to explain that wow but look at
these reviews that they included they
don't indicate what operating system any
of these are on
right they don't even include that
information they don't even have the
evidence right which is the whole point
their whole lawsuit is just there's no
there's not they don't even plead like
they don't even like plead basic
information yeah here
Ponzi Cav the user is
I was just chilling and then it just
flipped okay well so we know that
variety wrote an article about him
running a Ponzi scheme right yeah so
that explains the name he probably read
that I heard about that yeah they
probably heard it from variety
yeah you guys heard of variety it's like
a huge publication big tray paper and
then he they admit that it was flip so
why the [ __ ] is that my fault
skip go to page 10 billion
here page 11.
I wish I could give triller a rating of
0.25 stars the app bombards you with
information as soon as you open it when
I open triller on my phone I immediately
confronted with the CEO of triller Ryan
Cavanaugh who's accused of running a
Ponzi scheme by his ex-partner variety
he obviously read that article the CEO
of trailer Ryan Kavanaugh looked
shockingly Harvey Weinstein I mean
that's just plain to see
like you
that's just plain to see I mean I don't
know why you would put that on me
um whom has a personal ties with yeah
you see I've seen pictures of them
together he has an overwhelming foot
odor
see I don't know anything about that
I don't know why but I just smell feet
when I open this app I'd rather submit
to the tyranny of Mark Zuckerberg and
give Facebook complete control over my
identity and self
sense of self then use trailer for even
one second longer than I already have
sorry that your app sucks dude not my
[ __ ] fault
[Music]
you know
foreign
look at this I sense a lawsuit coming
from Tick Tock as this is a direct
rip-off except 10 times worse one star
what does that have to do with me your
honor yeah that's a common sentiment
it is a ripoff of tick tock I mean
straight up
yeah and he was colluding with the
trumps well that's probably something I
should put an asterisk snare
wait wait
was Trump when when Trump was trying to
shut down Tick Tock that's the only
reason why anyone even gives a [ __ ]
about trailer yeah and now all of a
sudden he's like besties with the trumps
and also with Steve Munchen apparently
he's besties
in these nuts oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] God
oh my God
look here's one uh so awkward one star
that's Noah back play attack
he's quoting lower back
I never said that
Jack's so awkward thank you why is it so
awkward yo trailer my thing's flipped
their own [ __ ] user this isn't he
owns portions of trailer Noah back right
uh it's all flipped he may be yeah like
he's investors he's in deep man so your
own people are saying one star
I'm checking out it's gonna be like 20
minutes
huh
yeah so you know
200 pages of this [ __ ] let's go to the
bottom let's see we've got the last spot
let's see here
all the way down boys and girls
um
the very last one here
that they're pinning see this one even
got two stars like by the way some of
these have five stars this is a
five-star review
you put in a five-star review you want
to so so what's
so beautiful app for tick tock copy
that's the review from madhav gamer five
stars what the [ __ ] bruh
someone want to explain that [ __ ] to me
that does seem like an oversight does it
not so if I'm responsible for the one
stars then clearly I'm responsible for
this five-star review as well this is
insane you've consistently here's
another phone wait wait here's another
one this app is fantastic and the videos
also it's a copy of Tick Tock but
wait dude look at the dates
did you catch this
it says January 9.
that was like way before any of this
started was it not
I don't know
what was the Jake Paul fight it was okay
in like spring of this year
this is such a it was April I believe
yeah so there's they included [ __ ] that
was before you even knew anything about
triller or Ryan Kavanaugh so basically
this is a bad faith the same [ __ ] they
do they dumping a bunch of [ __ ] here
that like has nothing to do with me and
and trying to confuse the drug the judge
big massive dump it's pathetic how could
they [ __ ] that up like they [ __ ] up
everything they're literally just worse
[ __ ] lawyers no they're lit all
they're trying to do is bleed me dry
this is a spite lawsuit they're trying
to waste as much money as possible it's
crazy it's literally a spite lawsuit
they call them dumps oh and then we have
to respond to all this [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying like here this guy says
the app is fantastic I like it five star
really wow
that's rough sorry you had to read that
Ryan
that was clearly my fault right
I'm sorry for I'm sorry for influencing
people to like your app [ __ ]
what an [ __ ]
yes so anyway in honor of Ryan Kavanaugh
[Music]
we actually well thanks to love this is
kind of a passion project of mine and
loves I'd say yeah yes you guys really
really blew me away with this one
well there's been a lot of confusion
about Ryan looking like Harvey Weinstein
how do we tell these two gentlemen apart
um
I guess I shouldn't car have you
gentlemen I say I use that colloquially
so we made a website does Ryan Kavanaugh
look like Harvey weinstein.com
you can visit it now it's a
comprehensive analysis it's a public
service
oh look at the mic flag on yeah it's a
variety so he has heard of it oh yeah
so you have heard of variety Ryan
does Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
Weinstein the public is confused right
we asked 10 600 internet users if they
thought Ryan Kavanaugh and Harvey
Weinstein looked alike the outcome was
shocking now this is a poll we did on
the podcast July 30th now nine what is
it uh look I mean this is overwhelming
these are all look alike I think it was
approximately 95
95 think they looked alike so clearly I
was part of the five percent which which
means everything yeah saying that he
doesn't really I know you've been
holding out five percent difference is
astronomical
yeah so the public is confused
so now basically despite looking nearly
identical they are different people so I
just want this is basically I'm clearing
the air for Ryan
uh clearing the air in the sense of
you're making sure that he knows he's
not Harvey Weinstein right that they're
oh I see well I don't know if people are
like yo Harvey Weinstein let's get him
when they see it okay yeah that's a good
point that could get dangerous so just
to be clear this is the guy that's suing
me right who just who just published 200
pages of one star and five star reviews
right
before and after our our copyright
infringement right
and this is Harvey Weinstein alleged
copyright infringement by the way
right well well the thing is fair use is
like copyright infringement it's just
legal copyright infringement can you say
can you a b them again I think I
couldn't spot them so this is Ryan here
that's Ryan
this is Ryan this is Harvey I'm afraid
I'm afraid I think it's I think you're
flipped I think oh it's flipped yeah
it's it's wait this is Ryan
that's that's Harvey I don't know about
this website clearing the air hold on I
think you need to scroll down wait
there's no name key there's we need
names here yeah yeah yeah because I'm
okay let's go down maybe you know what
it says right below there Ryan and
Harvey so I'm gonna assume the left is
Ryan because his name is this is right
that's right okay that's what I thought
okay yeah well let's go down we'll clear
it up okay okay this is good so here
Ryan is on the left and Harvey is on the
right
so this is Ryan Kavanaugh
okay and then this is Harvey Weinstein
right and you can see the similarities
so does that help clear it up or is it
still confusing
yeah
I hope that helps I hope that helps well
there's another one here okay this one
is better so this one so Ryan is on the
right this is Ryan and then this is
Harvey so you can really tell you can
see how similar they are so that's
Harvey look at the ice yeah you have to
look at the name oh okay in the top
right it says Harvey so Harvey's online
which means if I move it to the right
it's Harvey that's Harvey yeah this is
hard
you seem to be flipped once again I'm
sorry I'm it's very they look very
similar okay I see I see so this is
Harvey Weinstein that's correct okay
this is Ryan Kavanaugh uh this website's
gonna you got it a lot of people yeah
yeah the public is confused yeah they
are well uh go ahead love you're the
artist for that I mean it's very
important that we let everyone know so I
just want to implore our fans and
viewers to share this website on our
Discord or no sorry on a Reddit and just
upload all the posts with this link on
it
and we cannot just vote up each other
yeah I hear that that helps the SEO a
lot well I want more people to see the
website because the public is confused
and when you know go ahead love you're
doing great okay so one more one more
thing there when you try to find this
website don't write it in the address
bar directly well let me let me stop you
there love it's just it's too long of a
title to type directly into the URL does
Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
Weinstein it'd be better to type it into
Google in case there's a typo or
something like that right love
that that clears everything out there is
no issues there's because the URL has to
be exact and that that's so hard right
yeah it's a lot of words take up a page
from from the Don Arc herself Donna and
you know Google the website that you're
trying to get let me do it right typing
in it so like this does
Ryan
Kavanaugh look like Harvey Weinstein
question mark yeah I see you had to type
it right there that would have that
would have thrown everything oh so here
it is number one yeah oh okay it's not
easy I had a typo wouldn't have worked
right so you just click this
and spend some time on the page reading
it
oh yeah for sure that's there's good
information here which we'll get into
yeah
so we get we did these side by side the
public is confused I said alarming
something must be done and Noah Beck
famously said my thing is flipped
right
so those are two members of the public
uh it's all flipped
um if you go here it's just kind of a
general this is actually if if you hover
over you will see the names
on your hover I thought that was memory
I thought that was Ryan's DUI right
there but that's Harvey I guess the one
where he's being held up oh yeah no
that's okay okay so the names are
helpful
you know Ethan and lava I really have to
thank you on behalf of the public for
making such a uh beautiful well thank
you for saying that we worked a lot it
was very it's an important project for
us you know we like to do Charities we
like to do public or PSAs yeah so this
is just a long line of our Public
Services yes so in the top right let's
try the game top right that looks like
Harvey [ __ ] it's Ryan
so we still have a ways to go
but uh we can get better I think study
them like you know flash class right
yeah exactly
okay so go ahead you want to try one
yeah the left that's Harvey top left
that's our left that's Harvey nope
that's Ryan damn it I got a story dude
that's Ryan
uh Ryan Cavanaugh Harvey Weinstein the
pictures below display a seemingly
friendly relationship between the two
former movie Producers so here
we kind of just showed a little bit just
like especially when you see them side
by side which you often did
how confusing it can be
um as we've we've we've exemplified with
the red markings here circles see as
Ryan looks at uh with adore adoring eyes
on Harvey
look at his attention he is a full
attention on Harvey here
uh look at these bodies I mean even
going as far to kiss Harvey Weinstein on
the head
you know you know this might this might
just be the weed talking
but I don't I don't see the resemblance
I mean that's fine I wish I wish my my
objective with this website is to have
more people relating with your
perspective than vice versa so you're an
example of this website working Dan so
you must have I did spend a lot of time
on it yeah you must have like high
facial awareness yeah because you've
heard of like face blindness where
people can't tell the difference right I
have the condition that's the opposite
of that yeah you have high facial
awareness I have that yeah I feel like I
see James Charles just everywhere
everywhere where I go right true that's
true so we wrote up a little bit about
um Orion by a biography oh he but so
this is just there's a big unibrow here
we added
and it says this image is altered so you
can tell Ryan apart from Harvey easier
so this is not we added this this is
unibrow Ryan Cavanaugh also do all of
the images of Ryan Kavanaugh have a
unibrow then just this one I'm not
really sure how that the future okay
well when you see the whole body it's
anyway let me read his biography Ryan
Kavanaugh is an American film producer
and film financer he is the founder and
former CEO of now bankrupt's relativity
media this studio was the third largest
mini major Jesus how many are you gonna
it's like third largest mini major
Studio a lot of qualifiers there yeah
before bankruptcy hit back in 2015 some
uh speculate that the bankruptcy was due
to poor management
now he's the CEO
or I guess majority owner of trailer I
guess it would be more accurate
Ryan Kavanaugh is also the owner CEO and
brain behind the app website and brand
triller trailer is a video sharing
platform similar to tick tock uh the
platform has recently garnered an
increase in downloads because of
prominent podcast H3 podcast has
promoted it and actually maybe what we
should add love is that it's it's been
it has had five star reviews attributed
to the H3 podcast
such as and then you can include those
ones in the complaint they showed
yes I'll love that for sure it seems
like very important
um the platform is not as giant as its
Rebel Tick Tock but it does have major
names such as Charlie and Dixie dimilio
oh that you did the same typos they had
right
oh that's a mistake yeah Justin Bieber
Josh Richard's no back oh not Kevin Hart
he's been removed tiger
sweaty and the weekend the weekend
awesome also spelled wrong right so
there's a little bit about Ryan uh he
actually has DUIs in October 2008 while
still on probation for an earlier
conviction for a DUI Kavanaugh was
arrested for drunk driving speeding and
driving with a suspended license from an
earlier conviction for DUI sounds bad
uh that was in 2008 and 2018
he lied under oath 2018 claims of sexual
harassment from Seven women at
relativity against former relativity
co-president Adam Fields was found to
have been the result of fraudulent uh
memorandum drafted according to the
Arbiter Judge Terry Friedman by
relativity CEO Ryan Kavanaugh himself
the attorney who Kavanaugh testified
who testified authored the memo
denied authoring the memo during her
deposition and was not employed by
relativity when it was created as a
result the art the Arbiter awarded
Fields 8.44 million after a forensic
audit on the computer was conducted it
was found that the memo had been
generated from someone who signed it as
Cav
ious clue as to the Memo's author
Ponzi scheme 2019 one year later 2019
Elon Sparr signed a complaint under oath
alleging that Kavanaugh persuaded him to
go into business together under false
pretense the suit however was resolved
out of court this story was covered in
June 7 2019 Variety article Ryan uh Ryan
Kavanaugh Accused by ex partner running
a Ponzi scheme
do we need to make any amendments to
this
I don't know what your lawyers say
I can't talk about what my lawyer said
okay
it's uh privileged fair enough
I think our audience has heard uh on
these stories once or twice before on
the show well I don't know if we need to
read it in an exclusion in detail
not really I find it fascinating okay
well what else up to you yeah I mean
Kavanaugh he stiffed his babysitter
mm-hmm she had to sue him for 175 000.
after he abruptly fire her two months
into a 13-month contract
um anyway you can read it that and more
we're constantly updating the website
right love yes yes all the time yeah so
I guess if fans want to like write texts
and stuff or or like original text maybe
that we could add that and stuff maybe
oh
who knows fans submitted content well
we'll have to vet at first yeah we need
to make sure it's factory suggestion box
or something yeah
yep so um yeah go ahead and check it out
Google it and uh just shout out for this
huge public service and I'm gonna give
myself a pat on there very impressive
guys very impressive love Ethan you guys
really put together something special
here thank you so much
well the food is here and I know you all
got Munchies it is and we've also been
going for a little
over two hours oh [ __ ] so let's wrap it
up hope you guys had fun we're about to
get some bogas and uh we'll see you guys
on uh on a little Friday that's right
laughs